j'accueille à présent sur ce plateau
Karine de bonsoir vous êtes enseignants
à l'école élémentaire centre des
carrières avoisin le Bretonneux et
bonsoir également à Lucie 9 ans tu es
élève à voisin de bretonneuse nous
allons découvrir tous les trois ensemble
le chiffre de cette édition
10504 il va s'afficher sur votre écran
c'est le nombre d'élèves de 3 à 25 ans
qui participent au projet banlieusard
banlieusards c'est mené par la salle de
spectacle la Marisa trappes avec
plusieurs établissements scolaires sur
50 ans en Yvelines c'est tout au long de
l'année également à Saint-Cyr-l'École
Rambouillet et au Mesnil-Saint-Denis des
communes voisines chants arts plastiques
films des artistes qui envahissent les
écoles pour y faire vivre la culture
cela existe depuis 1992 et cette année
votre classe donc y participe une classe
de CP donc un voisin de Bretonneux plus
précisément vous menez un travail
d'adaptation d'un album jeunesse comment
ça se passe
il s'agit d'un album qui est un conte
qui s'appelle Marie des grenouilles de
Jean-Claude Grimberg donc c'est une
adaptation bien sûr donc nous avons une
artiste une comédienne qui qui nous
propose donc une réécriture et qui
intervient d'abord à l'école pour une
vingtaine de séances et ensuite nous
produisons un petit spectacle à la
Meurice une vingtaine de séances avec
une comédienne comment se passe ces
séances en fait nous sommes deux classes
on est deux collègues on travaille
ensemble donc
ça fait beaucoup d'enfants et on tient
absolument à ce que chacun est un tout
petit rôle alors après ça dépend des
élèves il y en a qui veulent participer
davantage il y a des enfants plus
timides donc on respecte mais on essaye
de mettre tout le monde en valeur alors
comment vous accueillez l'arrivée d'une
personne extérieure dans votre classe
comment se passe le projet pédagogique
aussi en fait on en contact auparavant
avec elle on discute ensemble de ce
qu'on a mis ce qu'on aimerait faire donc
là ça fait trois ans qu'on travaille
avec la même actrice Catherine laine
parce qu'on trouve que elle ça colle
bien avec elle on est elle s'adapte bien
à l'âge des enfants et donc on se rend
compte auparavant et on définit un petit
peu sur quoi on veut travailler elle a
aussi des propositions et voilà donc le
rendu la restitution ce sera pour les
parents le 17 juin à la mairie quel
bilan vous pouvez en faire jusqu'à
présent avant même qu'il se produit sur
scène oh bah c'est toujours un bilan
très positif les élèves justement
ça leur apporte de la confiance en eux
déjà parce qu'ils sont toujours
valorisés dans ce travail ils apprennent
ils découvrent aussi un métier parce que
qu'est-ce que c'est que d'être comédien
il travaille des textes ils apprennent
des choses par cœur donc c'est c'est
très très positif et très peu de travail
que vous ne pourriez pas mener sans
intervenant extérieur ça apporte quelque
chose aussi différent quelque chose de
différent d'abord parce qu'on a une
professionnelle donc qui fait la mise en
scène donc ça nous saurait pas faire de
cette manière là et en plus on bénéficie
des moyens techniques de la Meuse avec
un plateau un éclairage le son enfin
toute la mise en valeur comme des
professionnels quoi presque comme des
professionnels Lucie l'an dernier tu lui
a participé comme une professionnelle
comment ça s'est passé sur la scène
ça s'est passé bien
c'était difficile d'être face à un
public tu avais un petit peu peur
il y a une petite anecdote parce qu'à un
moment dont tu avais un rôle plutôt
important vous étiez deux sur scène à un
moment et il y a mon camarade qui a
oublié son thé son texte et j'ai eu un
trou alors comment on fait dans ces
moments-là
par exemple ce genre d'expérience c'est
typique c'est ça qui apporte aussi de la
confiance de la confiance à ses élèves
la face à un public presque s'enfiler
effectivement c'est sans filet le
théâtre puisqu'on peut pas refaire la
prise donc
je dirais que Lucie en plus elle a eu de
la chance parce qu'elle a fait deux fois
elle a participé deux fois en CP et en
CE1 donc là ça mésaventure ça s'est
passé l'an dernier c'était déjà sa
deuxième année théâtre et donc elle a
très bien géré la patienter on a soufflé
un peu en coulisses et puis voilà le
spectacle continue cette année est une
participe pas au dispositif banlieusard
mais pour autant est-ce que tu pas envie
de faire du théâtre tu as fait du
théâtre depuis cette expérience cette
aventure
ça t'a donné envie ou pas du tout dans
c'était juste une expérience comme ça
permet aussi peut-être pas de révéler
des vocations mais en tout cas de sortir
certains élèves peut-être et ça m'est
arrivé que des élèves du coup
s'inscrivent dans une activité théâtrale
par la suite parce que justement ils ont
voilà ils ont dépassé leur timidité et
ça leur a donné envie de continuer et ça
vous le sentez ensuite en classe par
exemple les élèves qui participent si
vous les avez l'année suivante ou dans
au fur et à mesure de l'année vous vous
sentez qu'ils ont gagné il y a des
enfants qui sont vraiment timides au
début et justement on essaye
particulièrement à cela de donner de
l'importance lors d'une d'un spectacle
comme ça et souvent il se révèle parce
que là vous participez c'est l'opération
dont nous parlons avec une restitution
sur scène le 17 mais cela fait 7 ans que
vous êtes associés à ce dispositif ça
fait 7 ans bon c'est pas toujours du
théâtre j'ai déjà participé pour faire
de la danse un projet une année c'était
un chanteur qui est venu donc il a
composé une chanson mes élèves et donc
ils se sont produits ils ont chanté
leurs chansons enfin c'est très varié
donc justement c'est ça qui est qui est
agréable dans ce projet et là les élèves
sont prêts pour le 17 oui
ils sont prêts vous avez tout de même un
petit regret parce qu'on a discuté avant
le début de cette émission et le regret
c'est que le dispositif a un petit peu
évolué cette année ce qui a changé c'est
qu'il n'y aura pas forcément d'échange
avec les parents les élèves des autres
classes des autres communes comme celle
de Trappes par exemple qui est à vos
enfants ce qui nous plaisait beaucoup
dans ce projet c'était aussi un échange
la formule auparavant nous allions faire
le spectacle avec un public scolaire
dans l'après-midi avant de le montrer
aux parents le soir et là cette année
c'est pas possible seuls les parents de
nos élèves verront le spectacle et je
trouve que c'est dommage parce qu'en
fait c'était bien de mixer les
populations déjà et de voir ce qui se
passe dans les autres écoles que font
d'autres enfants ailleurs c'est vrai
quand on a 6 ans on imagine pas trop
quoi et c'est ça qui vous avez poussé
vers dispositif oui aussi
une bonne initiale je trouve que c'est
une bonne initiative parce que bon bah
là je suis dans une école à Voisins où
les enfants vivent un petit peu dans un
petit microcosme là et donc je trouvais
que c'était une bonne ouverture d'esprit
d'aller voir dans une ville juste à côté
un théâtre qui est magnifique en plus
donc et de rencontrer d'autres enfants
très différents d'eux et qui font autour
d'un projet commun donc on fait la même
chose la toile si justement comme tu as
participé les années précédentes l'année
dernière notamment tu avais échangé avec
des élèves des autres écoles
il faut dire oui
c'est très rapide mais le fait de voir
ce produire d'autres classes c'est
intéressant quand même
tu te souviens plus d'où ce qu'ils
avaient fait apparemment impressionnés
vous nous l'avez dit vos élèves sont
prêts pour cette restitution le 17
banlieusards c'est une cinquantaine
d'enseignants qui sont engagés dont vous
à Voisins le bretonneux et ce spectacle
Le 17 s'est ouvert uniquement pour les
parents qui veulent assister au grand
public
peut venir si vous voulez voir ce que ça
donne un petit peu le travail avec des
élèves au quotidien et cette culture qui
est menée par des artistes au sein des
écoles merci